[Music]
just a few weeks ago my next guest Wow
Dan international audience of millions
with his incredible and unusual display
of athleticism during Madonna's Super
Bowl halftime show he's the face of a
new sport known as slacklining
please welcome sketchy Andy Lewis thank
you today I have not even heard of this
sport and then I'm watching the halftime
show and you come out and start jumping
on a line this must have turned your
life upside down since the Super Bowl oh
yes definitely my phone actually rang
itself to death three days in a row
really just yes so cuz I think well over
9 billion people watch you in a toga
jumping up and down which leads to my
next question a lot of people worldwide
were concerned about your health after
that performance would you want to
elaborate on that you know they were
very concerned about my testicles that
yeah yeah you know I didn't realize that
having balls of steel was a talent yeah
it is but actually was that was one of
the most tweeted concerns was you took
some landings and it just looked like
impossible that you wouldn't have been
hurt do you have a technique for
preserving that area I have full control
of my Vince Lombardi's actually now so I
can choose a side of the line to do it
on you know see that to the left if
you're being serious let's send that to
the right oh that's
I'd like to talk to you more about that
later how did this sport get started I
mean did someone just see a clothesline
and start jumping on it in a toga and
then everything took off from there you
know it was it was really close to that
you know wish togas were still in style
but it started off in the assembly with
chains chains went to webbing eventually
I saw the webbing set it up it got
tighter we started doing tricks and now
that now that a it's perfect tuned right
now for slack low flat you and a few
other slackline pros are gonna do some
moves for us right now so let me get out
of the way and go into a safe for sure
I'll be over here and you brought up
ahead the US pro team now here we go and
we're gonna slack that roll the music
Jimmy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
you